hello everyone this is emily here from
audio science review
welcome to the uh debunking channel
which seems to do what i
have to do every other day as far as
videos giving your requests
so uh today we're going to talk about
the usb
cables do they make an audible
difference do they make a measurable
difference
let's find out i think there'll be a
message for
for everyone no matter which camp you're
in
first i want to actually talk to rcamp
the objectivist camp
and the notion that the usb is a digital
transmission cable therefore it can't
possibly make a difference
in the output of an audio device attack
usb deck
back in 2017 i ran a
set of tests with my old audio precision
analyzer so the display looks a little
different than
my newer one and what i did was that i
took a [ __ ] modi 2 deck and you'll see
me use this stack
often in my videos when i want to show
sensitivity to jitter and noise the
stack is a
much older deck than the
state-of-the-art ones that shed sells
today and
uh it's powered over usb and uh
it it's fairly sensitive to nature of
usb so
i can even plug it into one usb port on
one machine and then
another machine and have the results
vary so
you know uh when i try to show sort of
the worst case susceptibility for noise
over usb uh i always use the shed mode
too
and what i did was that i tested it with
the sonora mark rendo which is a
streamer
so the streamer was a sort of appliance
streamer
running linux and uh i used a long
uh you know cheap crappy thin usb
cable it was a 28 gauge
cable and
it was six foot and then i compared it
to a six inch
generic cable so both of these are
generic cables just different lengths
and as you see in here there's quite a
bit of measured difference in here this
is our
12 kilohertz tone that you often see in
my jitter test
and the longer cable produced
more of these spikes jitter or noise or
whatever they are
in this stack so absolutely we can
measure the difference
between two usb cables anybody who says
that our instrumentation isn't good
enough
to measure such differences is wrong
um we can and i'm showing you right now
that we have indeed measured
um at the time i also had this fancy
audiophile usb cable um
some random brand uh from triad wire
labs called the uar
link um and it's a pretty short cable
and uh i compared that uh to the
short generic cable it actually uh was
worse performance
so just because something's audio file
cable obviously
doesn't mean that it's been tested
properly and measured properly so in
this case with this sensitive dac
um the one in red is our fancier
audiophile cable even though it's short
it still produced uh it produced worse
performance
nothing much but but it was measurable
and then i finally had this little stub
uh usb cable which is just you know goes
from one to the other with
no length between the two uh it's rigid
and we see that the rigid one is
actually better
than the uh even the short generic cable
that i had before
so uh length is your friend in here um
the longer the length is the more ground
loops you create
between the devices on your computer and
that those can bleed into the deck
um and cause interference and cause
noise
so
be careful in saying digital's digital
bits are bits
in these arguments because that argument
does not hold because usb is carrying
data we are able to extract data
reliably in these short lengths
but it's also got power and ground and
the power and ground is used
in the dac and if a dac doesn't properly
filter that five volt before he uses it
and or it's not designed well and it can
get into ground loops
with the computer which happens to
always have a noisy ground
you can impact measurable
analog output of the dac so everything
i've showed you is what comes out of a
dac
i'm not showing you what's on the wire i
don't care what's on the wire
i care about whether my end audio
product is distorted or not distorted
we're absolutely able to measure with
our instrumentation differences between
these cables
and turns out the champion is the
shortest one the shortest one has the
least amount of voltage drop
and least amount of impedance between it
the ground for the deck and the ground
for the pc so
it tends to help with that with a deck
like a shed modi too
um i'll skip over these uh
but this is an important chart i was
lying to you with those graphs
you know that if you go back to all of
these scales what do you see
minus 144 to minus 120
so this is still uh you know below
threshold overhearing so i've
zoomed way in and then magnified all
those
variations if i don't magnify him and i
look at the best case in the worst case
this is the difference that you see not
zeros on top
minus 140s at the bottom and look at the
difference we're talking between minus
140 and minus 135 or minus 130.
so no case can be made of audible
difference here
i'm just showing that we have very
sensitive instrumentation
and the bits are not bits because we're
dealing with analog nature of the
voltage and power supply coming from a
computer or feeding into a dac and if
you have a dac that's sensitive this way
you want to be careful about this okay
actually yeah i can show you this one
this is on a behringer
umc 204 hd very cheap deck and audio
interface
and it actually showed no difference
even though it's a cheap
low-cost dac it actually you know you
couldn't see the difference so it took
that [ __ ] modi there's one specific
sort of unicorn of a dac that is so
sensitive to these things that i happen
to know about
and i exaggerated difference if i just
step up to another budget deck which is
this one
you see no difference and indeed if i
use chess current products or any other
half decent dac today you won't be able
to make
show repeatable difference like this but
just know that
extra at the extreme the argument is
right that the cables
can make a difference as with all things
tweaks in high end
there's always some element of truth to
them of course they don't
bother to measure or even know it
themselves so it
takes me to go analyze it and say here's
a bone you could have put this on your
website and show some difference um
so anyway so remember don't say bits or
bits
what you want to say is that you want to
have a competent dac
which costs almost nothing to design
doesn't care about these vagaries of usb
and
at any rate anything that's half fancy
will also have its own power supply so
for high-end users to go buy these
cables makes no sense what do they think
that their usb
interface in their fancy deck was poorly
designed and they needed a better cable
they couldn't do anything internally
to fix that problem sort of strength
imagination but anyway fast forward two
years later this is 2020 a year ago
i was given a cable from a popular
company kimber cable
uh has a stupid name of b bus usb
uh yeah it is a b bus but
come up with a better name if you're
gonna charge me uh
sixty dollars now sixty dollars there's
nothing for a high-end cable this is
like
to a high-end user this would be dirt
this wouldn't even be acceptable
uh usb cables go up to 20 000 now
depending on length or even more and i'm
not kidding you
i don't want to tell you the branding
given promotion but
there are companies that make 17 to 20
000 usb cable and i know people have
bought them
and claimed that it was night and day
you plugged it in and all kinds of
magical things happen
um this cable is kind of a i think it's
an ugly looking cable it doesn't look
high-end at all it looks like a
same old cheap cable you buy for 10
bucks
and it's got a couple of ferrari cords
on him but
uh otherwise doesn't
feel like a 60 dollar item to me uh
he says you will be shocked when you
hear what these kimber cables can do to
your music
for your music wow but it doesn't say
what kind of shock
maybe it's electrical shotgun i don't
know but if i'm paying 10 times
for a cable i hope so i hope i get
something that's
shockingly better um they have an
endorsement from chris connick here
who runs the uh an old site that used to
be called uh computer auto
audio file but now it's called the audio
file style
um and it's a it's an online
call review site i don't know how much
reviewing he does but it's a forum and
discussion and
folks hang out there um he says he's
been a customer forever
um and he had high expectations for this
usb cable
and as soon as he plugged it in here's
the original recording
i guess with any other cable he was
hearing something else with that
something else is i don't know
says i can't recommend it enough it's
very inexpensive for high-end quality
it is as i explained uh for fifty
dollars such an improvement is no
brainer so there's some improvement
um quit listening to interference uh
really i you know i listen to usb cables
all day long
uh i don't hear interference i don't
measure interference uh
somehow he was hearing interference
before and
uh trust me on this one pick up this
cable
and if it does what it does to his
system well he says he'll do the same
thing to your system
wow we're supposed to trust folks i wish
it was so easy i wish i could just tell
you trust me
don't waste money on this cable but
my style is when i give you information
when i give you opinion i'd like to be
able to back that opinion with something
trust me what does that mean why should
i trust you what are your qualifications
in hearing interference in usb cable
uh let's demonstrate that let's see you
uh prove that your ears are that great
anyway i'll go ahead and
and test this using my modern audio
precision analyzer
i'll plug in a modern dac
state-of-the-art deck but hey
still a cheap tag because i think top
indian id uh for 500.
i forget so not high-end by anybody's
high-end standard but
you know high-end by our standards uh we
plug in with kimbo
kimber cable uh spelled funny
and we see the superlative uh
performance of
of this dac distortion is below 130 db
noise floors almost fallen off the
bottom of my chart um
it puts out 4 volts as we ask it 4.05 8
volts coming out distortion
plus noise is .0094
percent so you got two more zeros to it
as a ratio
we convert that to sign at uh we get 120
121 db so at least five to be better
than threshold of hearing and uh
it's even better than that i'm not going
to get into psychoacoustics right now so
this is
exceptional performance so i then switch
that out and use what i use um just
which is this amazon basics usb cable
it's very supple which is what i like i
do a lot of removing and plugging things
in and everything i need
i like to have my cable feel good
and it's got nice connectors on it and i
really like it i don't like some of the
other varieties they have
i like this usb b cable
i've gotten their other usb micro usb
and i didn't like that but for regular
amazon basic doesn't get more generic
than this right i'm sure amazon didn't
do any
audio surveys with that so i plugged
that in and look at the
distortion again all these zeros nine
four what was it before
all those zeros nine four even this
right hand digit did not change
i mean imagine if i just blow on that
machine
probably making up a change to digit the
change but did not change
with that uh uh with this swapping cable
look at the output voltage 4.058 volts
before
4.05 8 volts before
one millivolts accurate frequency that
are on accurate
that are on accurate gosh i mean where
do you hang your head on you look at the
spectrum displays identical
noise interference distortion
all of that is encapsulated in this
measurement
uh the full transfer function of the
device
not a thing has changed
uh a bugaboo is jitter people think oh
there's
noise over usb that noise goes into a
dac and creates
jitter noise can cause jitter so don't
say that can't happen if you don't clean
up that five volt and you take it and
feed it as a reference to a to a dac it
can actually
cause modulation of the output and it
will
create symmetrical tones that you'll see
around the main tone
we actually do have uh some jitter in
this product uh
we can see them but guess what amazon
basics cable or kimbo b
cable identicals they're landing on top
of each other
you just can't separate them i mean this
is a
stress test designed to bring out jitter
if it exists
it's high frequency tone which
exaggerates
jitter the higher the frequency the more
jitter same amount of gibber
the hardest amplitude is it's
proportional to frequency
and uh we still see no difference
whatsoever
in this little tick here whatever this
is right here
that was also reproduced i mean this
nothing has been removed with this other
cable
and as it should be this is a you when
you buy
a proper desktop deck that i recommend
to you
it does all this stuff they know usb is
not clean i mean it takes two seconds to
put a scope on a usb cable finite lane
well you don't use that voltage as is
you bring it in they have dc to dc
converters that
convert that to other or in this case
may not even use the
five volt off of a usb anyway and
isolation is provided between the usb
interface
and the sensitive dac so that the noise
that arrives over usb
cable doesn't jump and pollute the
output of that
that can happen that's what i showed you
with the shed mode e2
here it doesn't happen i can take a 99
back and show you the identical result
so don't fall for this so i have some
explanation in here but i've already
talked to you about that um that
you know you can get noise if you have
really really poor dac but even then i
can't make a case of audibility
uh until you break the device where the
packets are falling on the floor and in
that case it's great
static actually it's not that the sound
state changes veils removed things are
more analog like
all of that when people sense those
things it's just manufactured by the
this creative mind the mind loves to
make up things i mean we have so many
neurons in there and we'd love to uh
think we're also right about all these
things it's just the human nature where
we're self-confident and that keeps us
from being always depressed thinking
we're gonna die
and so we manufacture uh
improvements in sound readily with our
brain
and when we plug in a new cable uh we
say wow look at this i paid
more attention it sounds better and then
you take it out and you program yourself
thinking that
the old cable must not sound as good and
indeed it won't
so there is some element of truth in
there between usb cables but
as soon as you go you know in anything
decent these days
it just simply is not material
all these high performance measurements
that you see that i show you
i use that amazon basics cable where i'm
showing you measurements
down to 160 db how am i able to keep the
noise so low how am i
keeping the interference from the
analyzer my
the source i use by the way this is not
some fancy source this is my everyday
workstation that's running right now my
streaming app
my audio precision analyzer has a cpu
pig
app that runs that sucks one core drive
and there's activity running this is my
everyday machine i may have email
running
all the stuff's running photoshop
running and
yet it's feeding data to uh on a generic
amazon basis cable to attack and attacks
analog output the final thing that we
hear is being captured and analyzed to
incredible precision
and yet we don't see any flaws
i mean these things couldn't be more
accurate i mean look at these values and
tell me
how could this this cable make a
difference it absolutely cannot
why did chris think there was a
difference
just pure imagination he just needs to
learn
how to do a control test a control test
simply says
look let's just use your ears and only
your ears not your eyes not your brain
knowledge of what you're plugging into
who the manufacturer is
that's just your ears we trust your ears
actually people say
we don't trust the ears we trust
measurements no no i love
i trust ears but i only want to hear
that what goes in your ear not what else
you
synthesize that oh you've forever been a
kimber customer you think
their cables are great so of course if
you forever think that and you plug in
their usb cable and it feels and looks
nicer he said wow
it it made a difference yeah your brain
will manufacture that it will
it will definitely think that the
problems that that effect wears off
because it's not real it's manufactured
it wears off
have a loved one i've said this 20 times
swap cables on you when you don't know
do it listen for a whole day listen for
a whole week do this for as long as you
need to do there's no hurry we're not
watching every day
just keep a log was it kimber cable was
it amazon basic was it kimber cable was
it amazon base
have somebody else switch them and then
hide them with a towel or something
where you can't see the cable
simple test somebody that believes in
the stuff
should do this bring your log first just
show us text we don't even need any
video proof
for now just do this simple test ten
times you ran this
you waited one day one hour six weeks
whatever long you want there's no
restriction on time we're not there to
make you nervous we're not there to make
you
uh stressed out if the results don't
come out the way you think you don't
want to have to tell us you could just
chuckle
so there shouldn't be any stress in this
blind test
you know but if you have if you can
prove 10 out of 10 times or 9 or 10
times you can tell which cable is
plugged in
you'll be a hero you you will have
changed the laws of physics when it
comes to audio
you you know if you just demonstrate
that
if you can do it quickly in a few
minutes fantastic leave a camera running
and have somebody else administer this
test that's single blind
that's fine doesn't have to be
double-blind as long as that other
person doesn't wink at you and tell you
what that what cable's in there is as
good as double blind we're not
you know masochists when it comes to
this but give us something other than
trust me
trust me this cable is great go ahead
and cough up
50 60 on a cable why
i don't you know give me some something
to go by we're not lemmings we're not
stupid
give us something these are measurements
why is the manufacturer showing any
measurements what is manufacturers
saying they improved
why are those improvements not
measurable
if they've changed how do they know
they're building the right thing if they
don't measure do they not test these
things in a factory
how are they testing what are they
testing for what if their chemistry is
wrong that day and they're building a
different kind of cable they don't run
now
so it's important to measure it's
important to prove your point have some
backup has some
reason that your opinion should be valid
anyway i won't bore you anymore with my
lectures hopefully you learned something
about
measure usb cables and evaluated see you
in the next video
bye bye